Dr ter mittle is a surgeon in New Delhi
he's fighting on the front lines of an
epidemic quietly sweeping India driven
by new Menace junk food we reduce the
size of the stomach which is called
sleeve
gastrectomy we have operated from age of
13 till the age of
74 initially when I joined my practice I
was seeing maybe one or two patients a
month now I am seeing 15 to 20 patients
a month in India almost one in four
adults is considered overweight or obese
if nothing changes the country's beasty
rate is set to increase by more than 80%
by 2035 this is not simply a story of
individuals making unhealthy lifestyle
choices in India and much of the world
larger economic and social forces are
threatening people's health and
prosperity
much of India's history has been
blighted by famine as recently as 1943
the Bengal famine killed up to 3 million
people even now roughly a third of
children suffer from stunted growth and
yet over the last three decades obesity
has surged and it's set to get worse
that's been accompanied by a rise in
cardiovascular disease and diabetes the
economic costs are enormous premature
deaths healthcare costs are productivity
losses resulting from an overweight
population are estimated to top $129
billion by
2035 almost 2% of its GDP it's a double
burden of malnutrition now malnutrition
means Under and Over now we are seeing a
lot of overnutrition as well Dr Arun
Gupta is a pediatrician and health
campaigner he is the co-author of the
junk push a report detailing how
changing food consumption threatens
health since the globalization the
marketing of processed and ultr
processed food has picked up that has
actually influenced a lot of dietary
habits one of the major input here is
unhealthy diet composing of ultra
processed foods high in sugar high in
saturated fat or high in Salt of
sodium throughout the country homecooked
meals are losing out to empty calories
and sugar in the span of a decade
India's consumption of breakfast cereals
and potato chips have more than tripled
while confectioning items and soda sales
have doubled India is a massive emerging
market for Western Brands sales of ultra
processed snack food and sugary
beverages Grew From $6.2 billion in 2009
to $32 billion in 2022 for companies
like Nestle unila or Kenova sales are
growing at Double Digit rates and who
are one of the main targets whenever we
go to a party suppose a birthday party
of one friend there'll be various junk
food items such as coke uh Pepsi I
really enjoy Magi and like noodles and
Ramon Burger King McDonald's Maggie
pasta chips Burger Pizza they tastes
very delicious India's new food economy
has created a public health conundrum
with the packaged food and beverages
industry increased ly affecting the diet
of 1.4 billion
Indians one remedy that other countries
have turned to is stricter regulation
Chile for example has an advertising ban
on television on certain foods between
6:00 a.m. and 10: p.m. it also has
restricted the use of child targeted
imagery in the marketing of these
products after these interventions were
introduced sugary drink sales dropped by
24% as well as calorie consumption
calories from sugar and calories from
saturated fat until now India has mostly
relied on the companies themselves
self-regulating how they convey the
nutritional value of their products the
results some argue are misleading if you
see the front of the pack you will see
that they claim that it's like 50% of
vitamin D rich in vitamin C no added
preservatives and it says very brightly
20% protein but if you look at the back
of the label you find the 46% of it is
sugar more than 13 g of sugar stabilizer
colors and flavors if you are telling
people that it is high in protein you
very well tell it is high in sugar and
high in fat also efforts are underway to
introduce a more rigorous system
throughout 2021 and 2022 Indian
authorities consulted health and
consumer rights experts and
representatives of food companies about
a new labeling system while health and
consum consumer rights groups argued for
a traffic light system used by much of
Europe which signals red for products
high in sugar fat or salt the eventual
conclusion by The Authority was for a
health star rating which assigns star
ratings for a product's overall
nutritional value not everyone was happy
Health Stars only point that this food
is either healthy or less healthy it
doesn't tell people that it is unhealthy
for example a pack of cookies may have a
very high amount of sugar but if the
manufacturers add nuts it could get
awarded a star for containing fiber
getting that regulation right has been
evading Us in the country so that is one
part of the story but what we are
missing out is you know working at
Community level with children with
parents families to create an
environment for healthy eating and
sustainable food environments p agraval
runs the food Future Foundation a
nonprofit that seeks to educate school
children about healthy eating the
foundation runs programs in schools like
this one in order to educate children
and parents it is so important to focus
on preventive strategy and use diet and
lifestyle as a entry point for this
intervention government or any
regulatory body cannot reach out to
individual citizen at all meal times so
at the end of the days it is about
individual choices while nutrition
Advocates seek tighter regulation that
may run at odds with prime minister
Narendra modi's strategy to attract more
investment from multinational companies
the fear among Health experts is that
the burden will ultimately fall upon
people to make healthy choices on their
own with little guidance from the
government one of the tactics they use
is the putting the owners on the people
they that it it is the people who are
choosing to eat wrong Foods it's not us
which probably is one of the strategies
which they have been using for tobacco
also that people are smoking by their
choice not because of the marketing what
cigarette to you smoke doctor the brand
named most was camel smoke camels the
cigarette so many doctors enjoy the
tactic is industry will become a part of
the solution they want to be a part of
the solution they enter into policym
bodies of course the government allows
them to do so as stakeholders strict
regulations and education have driven
down smoking rates across the globe
imposing controls on the food industry
may be necessary to fight India surging
obesity rates and the illnesses that it
causes diabetes hypertension joint pains
back pain varicose veins G Stone Heria
cancers infertility chest problems heart
problems it is putting an enormous
strain on our
economy a country once blighted by too
few calories must face a new battle with
too many empty
[Music]
ones